Now that we are done discussing XP Extreme Programming, I
would like to have a quiz, in which I make
sure that some of the concepts behind XP are well
understood. So, I'm going to ask you which of the following statements
about Extreme Programming are true, and here are the statements.
Because of pair programming, XP requires twice the number of developers.
In XP, code is rarely changed after being written. XP
follows the test driven development, or TDD, paradigm. The customer does
not need to provide any requirements in XP.
XP is an iterative software development process. So I
would like for you to mark all of
the statements that you think are true about XP.